comprehension comprehension as I've said
before is the key to success in language
learning it's not difficult to say
something it's not difficult to come up
with a sentence a limited meaning that
you want to get across but when you're
speaking to a native speaker who has
tens of thousands of words that they
potentially could use many different
ways of expressing the same thought or
responding to what you have said if you
haven't got good comprehension you're
not going to be in the conversation very
long you can struggle to get your own
meaning across but you have to have good
comprehension how do you get good
comprehension I think there are five
Concepts that I have felt in my own
experience have been very useful to me
the first one is we have to get rid of
the old idea that we have to know 95% of
the words in any given context in order
to be able to benefit from that well
first of all I found that even 5% of the
words if they are if I don't know those
words it's frustrating to read and in
fact that's what got me going into link
because I had books in Spanish and
German with on every page you know 10
words that I didn't know and I would
look them up in a dictionary and I would
forget them so that's not that
comfortable in fact although you get a
general sense of the meaning however
nowadays with online dictionaries and
with systems like link I personally find
that 10 to 15% unknown words is like a
sweet spot where I'm gaining more
vocabulary because if you are hoping to
improve your comprehension and improve
your vocabulary if you are only dealing
with texts that have 5% new words you
will take forever to increase your
vocabulary to a level where you can be
comfortable in a wide variety of context
so first of all with modern technology
push yourself a little bit take
advantage of online dictionaries take
advantage of systems like link and find
your own Sweet Spot some people might if
the subject is very interesting might
even accept a 20% unknown words I find
that tougher but 10 to 15% for me is
quite comfortable second of all
traditionally if you look at teachers
approaches to comprehension reading
comprehension reading strategies you'll
see this for example Scarboro rope which
talks about the various aspects of
comprehension to me it's an unnecessary
complication of something that's pretty
straightforward but the gist of it is
that we need prior knowledge or
background knowledge as well as
vocabulary and this is true research has
shown that front-loading vocabulary in
other words trying to teach say a list
of words that the reader or The Listener
is about to encounter is not as
effective as having content that the
reader or The Listener is already
familiar with prior knowledge so how do
you ensure that the reader can encounter
material that's familiar to them I think
one of the issues there is to let the
the learner the language learner choose
content that they want to learn about
they have to like that content
traditionally teachers like to come up
with all kinds of pre-reading strategies
asking questions and helping the learner
the reader infer or guess and I think
all of that is a complete waste of time
rather you can have the learner listen
to something in a classroom that kind of
primes the pump a little bit or you can
let the learner choose the content that
they want to learn from in which case
the learn will probably choose something
that they're already familiar with it's
interesting reading some of these
teachers manuals about what to do they
point out for example that person of
Indian origin say will find content
about something of Indian culture easier
to understand if they're learning
English uh that's obviously true but
that being the case why is it so often
that foreign language teachers basically
try to force something that is
culturally very different but connected
to the culture of the target language
onto the learner at an early stage all
of these things you can deal with later
on the main thing is to get the learner
engaged with the content and in that
sense familiar subjects things they
already have prior knowledge about is
far preferable also in going through the
sort of various Google Google searches
teachers when they get into this sort of
pre-reading they end up trying to direct
the reader at least in high school
classroom wanting to make sure that the
reader or the learner even in sort of
English as a second language class draws
the same inference you know the
inference that aligns with the
ideological persuasion of the teacher
there's a time and a place for
everything and if the teacher is more
interested in promoting their ideology
whether it be leftwing or rightwing
rather than just letting the reader or
the learner absorb the language and draw
their own inference even if that
inference is wrong it doesn't matter
that you know interpretation of the text
belongs to the reader or or the learner
the target is to let the learner or the
reader acquire words and acquire some
familiarity with the language some
fluency in reading so prior knowledge
yes but obviously prior knowledge can
only be acquired through a lot of
reading so the the sort of bottom line
here is do things that will enable or
encourage the reader to read a lot and
that brings me to the third point and
that is we shouldn't be again giving the
learner comprehension questions because
we should be encouraging the reader to
accept or the learner to accept the fact
that they won't understand that a lot of
what they listen to or read in a
language they're learning they're not
going to understand it I I sometimes
call this get it wrong the first time
when I worked in the lumber business we
had this quality control program where
they said get it right the first time
well if you're manufacturing get it
right the first time but if you're a
language learner get it wrong the first
time keep going you can always always
come back to it you know I also used
once this sort of lawn mower analogy
where if I'm mowing the lawn and I've
let the lawn grow too long I'm better
off to you know raise the level of my
knives so that I can go across the grass
you know cutting some of it and then
come back later on and take a second
pass make it easier for yourself take a
first pass get a lot of stuff wrong
maybe go off and do something else come
back again have a second pass and pick
up a little bit more we need to accept
the fact that we can get it wrong we
cannot understand it we don't have to
answer comprehension questions which I
find extremely annoying it's enough that
I have consumed a lot of words consumed
a lot of the language and all of that is
helping my brain get used to the
language you also want to sort of come
across these vocabulary items words
Expressions phrases in different
contexts it's also been proven that more
than the sort of frequency the sort of
repetition of the same items which is
sometimes the case Cas of people who who
study lists blocks flashcards whatever
what's more important is to encounter
the same words in a variety of different
contexts and that way it turns out the
brain is able to better retain them so
several passes over the same content be
prepared not to understand just keep
consuming the language however and this
is the fourth point you want to make it
easy on yourself so it's it is useful to
try to narrow the range of sort of
subject matter that you're dealing with
and I tend to do this if I follow a
podcast you know on politics in say
Arabic or on economics or if I can
narrow the range of subject matter that
I'm dealing with even if I'm dealing
with different like I'm interleaving in
the sense that I'm dealing with
different podcast episodes or different
sources of content but it's in a
somewhat narrower range of subject
matter I'll have a higher probability of
meeting the same vocabulary over and
over again I have then some familiarity
with the subject I have that prior
knowledge if I move away for example
from a political podcast to say
literature or something on an unrelated
subject having to do with you know
dating or something then it's going to
be much more difficult so stay within
the same sort of General range of
content and that way you're going to
achieve that goal of more familiar
vocabulary and some sense of prior
knowledge and finally a fifth point is
use the power of listening because while
reading as I've said before is a great
way to increase your vocabulary you can
look words up in an online dictionary
you can review them but the listening is
how I get into the subject matter
typically I listen first I'm curious now
I've got some sense of what it's about
I've got a lot of missing pieces then I
can go in and read and look up words and
get a better sense of what's there but
the thing about listening is that
listening goes faster in most cases
depending on where we are in the
language but certainly for a long time
the speed at which the narrator native
speaker is speaking is faster than the
speed at which we can read in the
language and so that means we're getting
a better faster sort of access to the
content that we're trying to read we
have some momentum when we start to read
and very often even if if the narrator
is speaking too slowly in fact it's a
disadvantage we start to lose track by
the time we come to the end of the
sentence of what he or she was saying at
the beginning of the sentence so don't
listen to material too slowly try and
force yourself to listen to material at
normal speed in fact I sometimes crank
up the speed at Link in order to listen
to it more quickly I can cover the
material more quickly and I find I get
in some ways a better almost like a
bird's eye view of what I'm listening to
by the mere fact that it's going faster
and in fact I did mention in a previous
video that there was this dyslexic
person whose name now escapes me who
developed the methodology of you know
listening at two or three times normal
speed in order to overcome his dyslexia
so there is some advantage in forcing
yourself to listen and to listen quickly
and of course to listen a lot to build
up your momentum and your comprehension
skills for when you're going into
reading so in
summary I've given you five strategies
for improved comprehension both reading
comprehension and listening
comprehension this is the key this is
the the base for your
progress in the language once you have
good comprehension you can work on
refining bits of grammar you can work on
improving your output but the key is to
get that good comprehension and one
important element is for you to believe
in yourself and for you to trust the
process if you keep on doing these
things if you keep on consuming the
language you will achieve your goals so
thank you for listening and I have
spoken before in comprehension so you
might want to check out these other
videos that I did on the same subject
bye for now